we're looking at circular motion that's
where we're up to in mechanic's okay now
you were doing some circular motions
just now right yeah had your person in
the middle moving around them in a
circle okay I hope you found it
interesting are a few different things
that we can notice okay
first let's go back to the beginning
there was just a couple of you right
there just and I think what was our
record speed I think it was at one point
what one point one six one four one six
seconds okay now we're all interested in
who can win and how fast you can go and
you know how not Wiggly you can make
inline and so on okay but we have all of
this language to describe like more than
just fast and slow we can say look see
one point one six seconds your first
scenario okay um I didn't make you do a
on a measurement of how far like you
know how far you actually walked but we
have a precise measurement for how far
that person on the outside went if you
just think in terms of an angle right an
angle how far was the annual that that
person traveled to the outside person
that's a little bit how far did they go
in whatever time as an angle they went
360 degrees all year come on wearing
wearing calculus land here so we're
going to go radians that's 2 pi radians
so it's about six point two eight okay
so because now we have a displacement
it's not like a young it's my life
displacement it's an angle displacement
that's okay we have a displacement
mm-hmm and we have a time right so if we
have an angular displacement at a time
that means we can work out an angular
speed can't we how fast someone is
rotating so for example if we call this
this we call this angular displacement
because that's how far they went
equals two pi radians okay I'm just
putting a six point two H so we can get
some numbers in our head okay well
what's the angular speed what angle has
it gone through well I guess you divide
and I don't have my calculator out but
maybe you do the cloister six wouldn't
it maybe a bit under six there we go you
can do it exactly two pi divided by six
yeah we go five points per second okay
so we had this language here of
displacement and speed that we're
comfortable with but we're just applying
it to angles no big deal okay
now because it's displacement in speed
that's what we're familiar with but it's
not the displacement and speed or
velocity we're used to it's all about
angles so therefore you know if we call
this say what's an angle what are we
usually claimed or something okay this
here this would be well it's change in
theta with respect to time right so this
is the feeder on DT right but of course
we already have a young we already have
a convention established for how to talk
about these kinds of things when you're
differentiating with respect to time
because that's such a frequent thing you
know when we're talking about a straight
line motion instead of saying X and B
and a you could call it X and X dot and
X double dot that dot means no it means
more than a - it means with respect to
time so this is Theta dot okay same kind
of notation just apply it right now let
me extend this a little more this idea
of angular motion right it's so
important and it comes up so frequently
and I don't like dots that we call it
its own special thing
its own special letter when we use we
call this they call it Omega okay that's
a lowercase Omega not to be confused
with a upper case Omega which is orange
I think electricity that kind of thing
so this is Omega this is what's talking
about annual spit it's just another
notation you can call it theta dot or
you can call it defeat up on D T they're
all the same thing okay
now just to push on it a little more
just to have the picture complete for us
we have displacement we have the
velocity okay
what would round out the picture what's
left acceleration right and we can use
the same kinds of logic I can find my
new marker the same kinds of logic that
we had in straight-line motion or in
projectile to say well how would we
write how do we express this okay so if
we talk about displacement speed
velocity and acceleration you can say at
a whole bunch of different ways that's
what happens when you get to
acceleration we've noticed this already
when we're looking at our introductory
exercises in acceleration sorry in
mechanics we could just say it's this
speed this velocity differentiated with
respect to time thank you
so you can call it D Omega on DT okay
it's just I mean we're used to saying
it's DV DT but we don't want to confuse
V with this velocity okay you can write
it all a bunch of different ways
obviously since it's the first
derivative of this that makes it the
second derivative all this right so you
could equally write it d squared DT
squared okay think with me there's a few
other ways we know it to write
acceleration it's just the same kind of
thing just with different labels give me
another example C double dot yep you'll
see that just as many times okay another
one you can give me another - we have
five ways of running acceleration right
okay yeah
that's um that's yes true it doesn't
come up much though I don't know why but
I almost never say that um think about
ways we expressed acceleration before
that were useful sorcerers like F equals
MA tap questions will always go right oh
yeah good you can go from here right and
you can say well I can write this as
Omega on the Phaedo remember how we do
that with chain rule because Omega right
that's just defeat on DT so if I put D
theta on D T key you see it cancels and
it gives you back this line okay and
there's one more way to write it
instead of 1/2 V squared it'll be half
Omega squared right so you'd say it's
all the same it's all the same it's just
omegas instead of ease and it's just
theaters instead of X's right because
you've got feet on representing angular
displacement okay so if you've got this
idea this is all about angular motion
okay so let's do a quick thought
experiment here right let's think of our
armed group of four people and they were
all going around okay
now what was the time what kind of times
did we get for four people was like
three seconds 2.3 roughly three seconds
okay so think about this person the
second person all right how long did it
take for them to go all the way around
and back to the original spot it's three
seconds right what about this third
person how long it takes for them to go
all the way and then it back to the
original spot also three seconds they
all take the same knowledge rate that's
why everyone's shoulders were together
in theory anyway okay but hold on a
second you've all gone through the same
angle and you've all taken the same time
1.16 three seconds eight seconds
whatever it was so your angular motion
is this
but the mission isn't the same right get
the person on the outside to tell you
that motion is definitely not the same
what's the person on the outside doing
there buddy they're moving away faster
there else that lazy guy in the middle
he's not going anywhere
right it's yeah yeah I know who position
themselves to be in the middle okay so
therefore there's not just angular
motion and evolution doesn't tell the
whole story right there's also and this
has a couple of different names I think
the most helpful name is Amelia motion
okay because we're not just thinking
about this angle in here right so fine I
fold it put it in axis we're also
thinking about a line on which they're
moving okay so that is you know this
kind of thing okay but obviously the
further you are away from the center the
faster that motion is going to be okay
now how can we express this
algebraically let's think about them
just like this let's think about speed
okay so if I talk about linear velocity
okay velocity is on is distance over
time distance over time this this
distance right it was an angle okay this
distance where is it it's more in a
straight line right so how do you
measure it it's a it's a circumference
right and because we're talking in
radians we can use Radian measure
language to express this this thing is
not just a circumference it it's an arc
it's an arc okay so I'm gonna have the
change in the arc length right so it's
not straight and it's distance over time
okay
but we know how to calculate parking
right obviously need two things you're
gonna need the egg or you're gonna Diego
and what was the other thing that you
needed to make out are thing in his
radius right so we want to say well
that's the theater that's actually Oh
now keep in mind we're just speaking
about circular motion so that means the
radius is the same all the way around
so this uh-huh right this is a bit
confusing but I think you guys this R is
it constant okay guys are constant so
therefore I can just just pull it out
right I just take that out so this is
going to be equal to AA outside of
de-feet up on BP right hold on we don't
defeat on the tiers we gave that a whole
name we called it Omega and of course
this makes sense right
what's our that's how far you are from
the center but further you are from the
center right this thinks constant this
thing's constant but it's bigger right
so therefore your whole speed is moving
faster this poor guy is my name is
little Hannah okay so that's the picture
these are the equations you've got two
different kinds of motion
you've got angular motion and you've got
linear motion okay now I told you just
had a couple of different names the
other kind of name that has and you can
maybe imagine why this is in some
textbooks it's called why do you think
they call it that yeah it's um if you
were to illustrate it yeah right
when we talk about velocity versus a
derivative right so it tells you kind of
like gradient at a particular point and
it was you the great other tangent right
so if I were to represent the velocity
there at that particular point it looked
like the tangent going off in that
direction and I guess we draw it longer
depending on how fast it's going